let's give an example if Jesus is not
Jesus okay his name was Yeshua or ASA
you know in that in the Semitic language
so you know if you tell some person from
from the West stage you know Yeshua
he'll be like what's he talking about
thread you know Jesus didn't wear a
t-shirt and jeans you know he was
wearing a thong and that's why a lot of
the representations of the old the old
Italian painter's you know he's depicted
as wearing a soap so imagine Jesus
walking down you know in LA or New York
or some areas do you have blond hair
blue eyes right well that's not true in
the church you thought maybe white kind
of yeah look I I don't know what to tell
you I was born in the Middle East 2,000
years ago the Bible's very clear about
that should be pretty obvious I don't
have blonde hair and blue eyes
yeah that's a surfer boy no that's not
that's not that's not academic correct
and that's why people are to be
academically honest you know Jesus is
described in the Bible as having breast
feed you know so he was most likely
equal to what he would see of
Palestinian be looking like today or
Jordanian or someone from that area you
know it was someone red and bronze he
was it was brown you know kind of like
and he had woolly hair so you know you
use not he was that he wasn't a white
boy let's just split it like that
I'm with Gabriel L Romani the last time
we met gibreel how are you huh huh you
forget about your brother no I remember
last time we had a nice little view
scenic you we were coming out of the
seminar and we had a nice little
interview we were talking about your
story yeah it's me la alhamdulillah
assalamualaikum welcome to another
episode of the Deen show on location and
we've interviewed all sorts of Muslims
all over the world I told you if there's
a Muslim on the moon we'd be
interviewing them but I found a Muslim
from Romania Romanian Muslim lovin islam
gibreel assalamualaikum
how are you brother good good to be here
I want to ask you a few questions
inshaallah so in a predominantly
Christian Orthodox Catholic Romania how
did you find Islam for the people who
didn't get a chance to watch that story
that interview kind of sum it up for us
what we talked about about your
experience coming into Islam so yeah I
was born in Romania 1998 and the first
sentence and what we learned back there
mindful peaceful you know there are some
people we have a history with turkey
Romania is always like that so you know
we're giving the raw deals in the media
so when I miss Muslims for the first
time and I experienced the reality and I
think that's the problem most people
they don't actually meet Muslims they
just see what's on the TV so when I met
Muslims for the first time I said you
know this is story different than what
I've learned like I want to know more
and that's what matters to a lot of the
discussion is a lot of increasing the
questions about theology about who is
God and what is faith and what is life
and what's the Hereafter and one of the
tipping points was when I saw my brother
Kamal smile of it was like one of my
best friend's way upon my best friend
and person who gave me down by the best
of Allah some on making sure dude at one
day were in Toronto in the morning and
it was funny time and that's one thing
about come on no matter what we're doing
going to places having fun
you'll never miss his prayer right so I
used to ask him how come you know like
we're having fun we're you know just
kicking it and you know why you're
praying you know I'm not praying and
he's like because I know what I'm doing
is wrong so this is my door to Allah for
repentance and I'm gonna change and I
really appreciate about him you know and
when I saw making certain
you would know something that obvious in
the Bible's Israeli spray which led me
to ask the question like what Christian
how come I don't pray to Jesus and he's
the Muslim he prays like Jesus
fast-forwarding there's a lot of
research and a lot of reading I was
hiding from my family I didn't wanted to
to know that I'm doing this spiritual
quest so I was reading a lot you hide
the books under my pillow I didn't want
to let them go slowly slowly I started
removing the icons from my room I
started basically leaving Christianity
and I left it because it was just not
you know it was just not the truth it
was it wasn't matching with what the
Bible has to say it wasn't matching with
what the church says and the Bible
doesn't mess with what I mean it was not
you know there was a three-way mismatch
so I basically became nothing and she
said I believe in God but I was fooled
and fascinating attracted to the to
Islam which led me to study more I
studied all the other world religions
philosophies and religions and I
couldn't fight the Islam you know it's
not just pulling pulling pulling and I
realized that Kamal this is a better
follower of Jesus than I was even though
I still I mean I said well he's in Jesus
even I was not Christian anymore but he
was a better follower of Jesus even when
I was a Christian you know compared to
me and that's because really Jesus was a
Muslim you know and that's that's what
was the answer is and there was a
tipping point in my life again where I
had a dream that you know life was
ending but I died and it really pushed
me to take the decision in the step to
embrace Islam was very lucid dream it
was something very real and you know in
a party and having fun and someone came
to Savin me and I went out in the
backyard and I saw a light in the
heavens and this life called my soul my
soul just lifted and I woke up and I was
crying and I felt so disturbed and I
said what if I died tomorrow like what
am I waiting for you know and that's the
question for all the viewers and
everyone if are we ready if two Moors
day that time is marked and it's you
know your Allah calls you like are you
ready are you sure that you can hook
your salvation on something kinda not so
sure type of ideology not so sure who
said it not so sure what his name is not
so sure really just the fields you know
nice so it sounds nicer it's very easy
it's not like that you know we have to
get serious so I have to get serious and
Hum Dil I know a lot guys at me that on
you know one night that called brothers
Kamal and you know I took Shahada with
him and yeah that's what led me to the
interview with you
here's pew years down the line and Here
I am today can you clarify when you say
Jesus was a Muslim for those people that
are shocked by your statement what ha
how can you verify that he was Muslim
yeah well basically Muslim or Islam
itself Salam Islam means to submit to
the almighty creator when I say creator
here because a lot of people get
confused or because they don't have the
knowledge of what Allah means or
Allah they you know they understand the
Semitic languages they're used to the
English language only so a lot of times
the human brain gets conditioned to Eve
almost think that somehow Jesus and God
is somehow American or something you
know what I mean and if they hear
something strange is different lingo is
different a different word being used
then they get all like no that must not
be true because doesn't sound familiar
to me you know and that's very
irrational no a Muslim if someone who
submits to the almighty creator of the
heavens and the earth and that is an
Arabic called Allah Christian Arabs
called God Allah you can go and ask
anyone you can pick up any Christian
Bible and you read the word Allah
moreover it's written in the Christian
Bible supposedly we don't really believe
that but Jesus on the cross suppose he's
saying Eli Eli lama sabachthani right so
you can obviously anyone could
understand the word Eli and that's
exactly what is a lot or lack the
different form expressions I'm using so
Jesus was a person the
is the one who does his snap okay so
Jesus was the one who submitted to God
and hence use a Muslim we understand so
he was the Prophet at that time he was
the truth the way their life whatever
you call it no one will come to God
except through him you know people like
to call diverse and of course we agree
with that because that was the case of
every prophet in their time no one would
ever be able to go to God except through
their prophet who was a Muslim and who
called to God and God only through pure
theology and when I say pure theology I
mean pure not something that needs to be
explained in external volumes and given
all kinds of similarities from the world
and still it's not explained I'm talking
about pure you know something simple
anyone can understand the child is a
child is born a child grows up he's
never gonna just naturally develop but
feeling that somehow God is a multiple
of different personalities under
different you know circumstances no
that's not how it is
naturally a person believes in the
divine and that's what's called the
fifth broward a natural disposition so
Jesus was just that he was a person who
was sent from God and he was a prophet
and messenger and he was a person who
submitted to God
hence he was a Muslim and we consider
Jesus one of the oldest animal Agusan or
one of these strong willed prophets or
the most important prophets of Allah
ma'am you mentioned having a dream for
the person who says well looked I've had
a dream - he might be a Christian or
Hindu and say well Jesus came to me in a
dream so what's the differentiate you
being on the truth via me being on the
truth yeah that's a very good point
that's why I mean this is something very
subjective
I never uses an objective thing but I
like to you know just throw it out there
because people connect - sometimes right
but I've spoken to Hindus to Buddhist to
Muslims themselves to say that for
example you know they saw Prophet
Muhammed agree with told them not to
pray anymore you know I mean and that's
that's invalidated and that's an
because we follow people based on how
they follow prophet muhammad saw seven
funny fault they follow Allah and as the
prophets we don't fault them based on
their dreams so yeah I can say that you
know I mean my wife lives on promise us
and it doesn't mean that okay so you
know you're gonna use that all the time
where there's been different people that
I've learned about Jesus many times
well not many times but at least a
couple times and it was a certain dream
now it's it's not something you can use
as something as an objective proof you
know what I mean but it's still
something personal for those who say
that I dream of this that I have no
doubt that they've trusted someone but
for his innocent there's an explanation
and Prophet Muhammad SAW says that the
ship to hunt can take the shape of
anyone in the dream except for him some
a lot of Silla so I have no doubt people
says I dreamed about Jesus about God
about this or about that there's no
doubt whatsoever about that if they
dreamt about someone but the question is
who is it right and how do we answer
that question is who is it as we look at
what they saw in that dream and what
that person asked him to do so for
example she have two positive Jelani the
great scholar islam he says that he was
dozing off and he was praying the early
days of you know of late hours of the
night and then he saw a drone coming
down from the sky and basically like
allah and he said to him or after call
them you've been worshipping me so well
you don't have to pray anymore right
some deposit said oh yeah doula or enemy
of allah disappear because you're
telling me something that i'll already
told me what he knows somehow that i
have to establish prayer so he telling
me has to stop right so i know that
you're not the truth you understand Imam
Shafi says that it doesn't matter
someone can be walking on water just
like Jesus did
someone can be flying just like other
you know so so many so-called Sufi
Saints or other people would have said
they've done no it doesn't matter we
look at how they follow God then we look
at their miracles if the two don't match
then it's an X because we know very well
because there's jinns and spirits and
other things that can help them do these
supernatural things
vision stuff like that but the reality
is has to be a litmus test and if you
look at these Christians whatever their
scriptures always dictate in the end
pure monotheism so anyone who comes in
be themselves or priests they're
scholars and try to say otherwise it's X
it's an invalidation of that main
concept like the first amendment and
what what tell you what have you seen in
your experience now you've been dealing
a lot in conveying the message of Islam
sharing it because you care you share
and you've been out there not just
living it yourself but sharing it with
others and trying to be an ambassador to
this Deen what are some of the
challenges the majority of challenges
doubts that you recently did a talk on
tackling and answering some of the
questions the doubts that people have
what are some of the top three doubts
that people who come into Islam or in
Islam and then they have in the neck
they end up struggling with yeah so
that's a very good question
see we have to understand that it's very
easy to fall into doubts and that
doesn't mean if someone just like
finished you know they lost their faith
no we as Muslims have to respond to
these doubts and that's because scholars
who look into this and not do what
preachers who take care of this and of
course the social media everyone having
a platform there are so many people who
instead of trying to circle the beauty
of their faith supposedly they try to
tap your pain right it's kind of weird
you know if you really want to do what
you believe then show me how nice it is
don't fight with just a doctor but
anyway to answer your question probably
is the first thing that's that comes to
a Muslim or a new Muslim line in terms
of doubts it's usually linked to the
rules and regulations of Islam
specifically the Sharia right when they
hear the word Sharia or law of Islam
they think it's like you know cutting
the hand stoning the adulteress or
whipping you know there's a drunk and
that's not what it is people kind of say
well sure it is so that's usually the
first question
so what is Shogun do you even understand
what it is so they actually don't know
what chili ice the problem is rather
that a lot of people are not educated so
they just throw things out there so if
you look at what the Sharia is Sharia
from Sharia it's a straighter passed
away that has been developed it's a rule
set of rules that includes government
includes banking includes health system
family marriage divorce burial you name
it you know it's got the military aspect
we have no doubt about it we don't shy
away from that but we come prepared very
simply and exactly even to a
constitution force much better than
anything like that what if I must have
nodded but what I'm saying is if you
look at any country's College
Constitution you will find within it all
these aspects including the military
aspect right so when people look at it
will they start accusing a certain
country of being violent or applying
certain rules and regulations and
punishments even within their judicial
system no they won't
right they will not but supposedly when
it's Islam because you know it's not
doesn't make that separation it doesn't
say that it's almost only good for
Friday or Saturday Sunday people have an
issue right because you know in the
other face with Reformation some people
can choose what I'll do Christianity or
whatever only on one day and the rest of
the day I'll do what I want but you see
the vacuum has to be filled so all those
rules and regulations in the end human
beings the way our psychology is we are
people that congregate we are societal
people so we lose the recognition so
instead of using God's rules and
regulations we've have to film the
vacuum with rules that are ever-changing
and you don't have a consistent system
of ethics and morals you understand so
people have an issue is that and they
look at the shitty on they say oh look
what you're doing well you just
understand the hoodoos or the hand which
are the punishments which is equal to
again a lot of the systems and the
Constitution's of all countries in the
world all of them have it show me one
country in the world that doesn't have
within its constitution some kind of
legal proceedings and punishments does
so so if you're gonna look at the Sharia
and look
that has you find that it's only small
book within a library of many many other
books but people love to piss on it why
because they're directed towards that
it's not just free they're directed
every time people keep saying so
psychologically speaking to the
repetitive affect the keep hearing in
the media Sherea Sherea Sherea Sherea
Sherea that's the first thing as the
mind starts producing Sherea you know so
everyone has an issue with it you asked
him what is Sharia I have no clue it's
cutting the hand no it's not from my
friend it's not cutting the hair it's
marriage it's love it's kindness it's
passion if some passion it's mercy it's
social work if so many things and you're
only looking at that one thing but
that's a very flawed way of looking very
irrational and illogical unfair you know
if we claim the real is in this 21st
century a world of you know giving
humanity and so on and people have to be
really fair and there'll be a loss if
they're not because they're missing out
on something so important and that is
truth and salvation you know if people
just give it some chance I'm not saying
just jump into something convert I'm
saying is give it a read give it a
chance open the Quran go speak to Muslim
visit of Masjid visit a an imam get your
question answer you'll find that it's
gonna be the world of a difference right
so that's the first thing second thing
second point people have issues with is
the character of prophet muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam again
because the measuring stick has been
wrong a lot of people tend to have
issues with the life of prophet muhammad
saw the live Center in the season of the
Prophet sallallaahu sullen and naturally
so because if you've been conditioned to
believe that ethics and morals are a
certain thing then of course you can
have problems and you know things but
these double standards very clear here
when he analyzed life the process of
Selim you see you can't have clean water
coming out of the dirty path it's just
impossible but that's all you see no
profit promised all centers just clean
water now did he have wars did he order
killing a certain people song yeah
because he was the judge and the state
ruler and leader of a country of
Constitution no doubt but again I go
back to my initial
go look at any country in the world and
you find that the same thing people
don't have an issue is that people write
certain leaders of the world went on
horrific things as culture and
civilization and great leaders of the
world and they study it but somehow
again when it comes to practice and
learn somehow people have an issue this
is again because there is a really sick
and he dealt with the situation when you
compare that to what happens in today's
world you find that the human beings are
at loss you know their ethics and morals
suppose they are you know perfect but
they're always changing our ethics and
walls are going down down down down down
the the customs countries people are in
doubt they're in there and they're in
panic mode you know they're losing their
children they're losing their their
ethnic ethnic their ethnicities their
identity people are committing more and
more schools besides there's mental
illness there's depression and the
question is again why problem is that
there's a contradiction in what
condition after all 7 didn't shy away
from dealing with situation so if you
have to kick some back he kicked some
back and if he has to put someone his
lacy put him in his place and that's
just the way it is look around the world
but at the same time use a man full of
compassion and full of kindness and
mercy and love and you'll find that
throughout problem is that academically
when he studies the life of prophets
Allah Allah the writers who wrote the
serie actually is called the Gaza Wat so
they Ruth usually around main events the
Arab used to write around main events so
that other ones were the battles so you
find that the seal of the prophets often
is usually written around some of the
major battles so when someone comes in
from Zion doesn't understand that they
tend to think that the process of all
you did is fight but it's not true when
you start studying the Hadees if there's
even song you find the social life of
the process of Saladin with children
with his wives with his family giving
coming establishing
currently establishing cities building
putting his hand there you know living
very syphilis look at all the leaders in
the world past and present and look at
their lifestyles and look at their
salaries those kinds they're living and
how they lived in with and look upon sin
because crime marks from the straw
mattress that he was sleeping on why
when he has access to so much money and
he you know the Arabia was already open
he could have bought the nicest still
owes from Persia and so on but no
because he was a servant of God and he
lived very parsley and he didn't take
the money from the people and so on he
only gave the facts the way you find
that what he left behind was nothing if
you look at the world leaders who
passively pass the president was they
each behind it's very obvious and this
indicates to his intention you know a
person who's trying to seek this worldly
life is trying to as some of your
Institute say that he was a power-hungry
person and money hungry person a woman
hungry person I mean his actions look at
his life and you'll find you know look
at the wait list and the ways that and
you find none of that right so people
would say this and this was a human
being that he liked women is why
hopefully this because I hope you know
something you know but I'm do like you
know I think so what's wrong with that
he married he was a dedicated man who's
a family man right today people are are
pushing any other you know type of
relationships and so on there are very
very enough donkey right so people are
have no problem with that but their
problem with marriages I mean when
person or person looks and analyzes like
to find sincerity in life from a
counselor so I feel like people are
missing out because they're missing out
his life they're missing out who he was
and they're missing out on him being
this the savior for this humanity you
know in the end the last Savior who came
to this to to mankind to two guys in
from the darkness into the light so
again what I'm saying is people just
needs to open up they need to look they
need to analyze they can't just pick up
any book here and there and just strive
to read or on the
Genet really they need to the way you
know I've done is that I've missed
Muslims and I have a Muslim
contextualized things for me everything
has a context if you just read things on
the internet you watch the video here or
book you're not gonna get a lot of
context look at the Muslims look at the
majority of Muslims and I'm talking
about a similar I'm not talking about
60% or 70% right I'm talking about 95 98
maybe 99 percent of the Muslims around
the world right look at the way they
lived because it has thick said morals
and so on and then try to compare that
so people who are missing out because
again they're being directed towards
that do my research through my you know
studies and our there is there's a
little systemized way of people kind of
push Muslims and non-muslims to hate
Islam and that's kind of critical right
because these are saying that we can
make peace why is that people who
netbooks need to feel out default
anonymously one and when it says to them
as Allah says in surah Baqarah and when
it says to them don't make facade or
evil on the earth the civil war
peacemakers I adore but indeed Abbas
says there are no students they are the
ones who are causing problems you know
you're trying to to incite hatred and
inside all kinds of you know negative
feelings and definitely you know you're
not gonna be a peacemaker for sure so as
Jesus said blessed are the peacemakers
so people are missing out and I think
the the third issue is is an issue of
desires you know people are confused
because of the desires that are around
the world today and sometimes the Muslim
community makes it so difficult for
someone to do something that's halal and
Haram is so easy so his time is not
gonna it tries to grab your eyes away to
commit [ __ ] he's gonna take you
step-by-step so you start with you you
know your sins you'll work on your
desires and slowly slowly the human
being as a Muslim or a new Muslim you'd
only have anxiety rise because you
understand what you're doing is wrong
and you don't want to do it but slowly
slowly you get a custody you get
accustomed to it you know and slowly so
you start justifying because you cannot
have the
sighing heart a human being doesn't do
well with anxiety so either 102 he's
there accommodate or simulates so either
accommodates itself his friend premium
of work his mind the way the mentality
is to an outside stimuli or he takes it
outside stimuli and he incorporates it
and whatever he believes already right
so that's the problem the the Muslim
cannot when there's a contradiction
between the two there's anxiety so the
human being naturally wants to get rid
of anxiety so I might be drinking or I
might be committing zina I'm not feeling
good because I know it's haha right a
lost man that says he swears to be
nothing low 1 he swears by the self
reprimanding soul it's a good sign when
you feel bad and you have anxiety but
the human being cannot send them so what
they'll do is they're dull repent and
they'll keep fighting all their gear
fuss and they'll change the ruling it
will say who says it's not on anyway why
do I have to feel bad and that's what
the Shaitaan how he works slowly slowly
so now who says that his job is is you
know how long if you don't work who says
that it's Haram if you you know commit
sin who sits around if you drink who
sits around if you do drugs
who said surround this is this why do I
have to feel bad right so a lot of
people are confused with that they said
why do we have to advise Maher all these
rules so you find that people slowly
slowly slowly drift off from the correct
path and they end up very straight and
then in the end they'll end up doing
[ __ ] right
so Allah you know it's like the story
that Sahaba who was seen later on in the
peripheries of the Roman Empire and he
fell in love with the with the woman and
he saw his one-person song this is what
happened to you he says Allah he I don't
know and he's they used to be a
memorizer of the Quran I mean he was a
half of the Quran and he said I don't
remember anything the Quran anymore
except for one verse and that is that
Ramana he was dueling a fellow can you
see me
that may be or it is the people
disbelieve they wish they will be
Muslims
you know that mean those the only words
that you remember from the cry forgot
the whole Quran because he founded the
Sunnah he moved away from the Muslims he
said free himself from society and he he
left Islam so but again I mean it's very
clear you know it's not doesn't take a
rocket scientist to look at what's good
and what's not what's ethical and what's
not you know what's authentic
traditional in line with custom and
ethics and morals and the identity of of
civilizations and what's not and people
are just playing with these things you
know just because they feel that they
have the right to do so everyone has a
voice today everyone can be on a social
media platform without any studies
without any knowledge and just talking
you know and all the people worked hard
and it's trying to teach people and
they're trying to work to maintain you
know faith based on what God has
revealed they usually being ostracized
and you know called you know has to be
an evil people so you see it as the
prophet Fossum said I mean we don't do
so because process has already predicted
these things and it says that you know
things will be flipped out but people
because the bad people about so yeah
this you know pretty much this goes back
to the word have you seen in your
studies because you're involved in
comparative religion that the word
Sharia is also mentioned in the Bible
over 200 sometimes and didn't Jesus
lived by the Sharia and Moses brought to
Sharia of course yeah but it goes back
to the first point that I made right
that foreign term if you use something
foreign you know people think I don't
like that that doesn't sound good
it's not right you know must have a
negative connotation Shetty yeah you
know it's like someone's just gonna jump
out a window or something and to take
you out yeah you know let's do an
example if Jesus is not insane it's not
Jesus okay his name was Yeshua or ASA
you know in that in the Semitic language
so you know if you tell some person from
from the West days you know Yeshua he'll
be like what's he talking about thread
he'll say you you know you weird that's
not Jesus it was what again is not is
Yeshua Yeshua Issa and the fact
matter is that's a fact because the
English language didn't exist so you're
a hundred exactly 100% exist again
that's the thing you know Jesus didn't
wear a t-shirt and jeans you know he was
wearing a thong and that's why a lot of
the representations of the old the old
Italian painter's you know he's depicted
as wearing a thoughts imagine Jesus
walking down you know in LA or New York
or sometimes I know he'll be probably
you know sent to jail or something no or
we call the terrorists but that's Jesus
do you have blond hair blue eyes right
well that's not true in the church
you're going to dress yeah what color
your eyes are like blue right so here
like you're kind of like you yeah yeah
was a surfer boy no that's not that's
not that's not academic correct and
that's why people have to be
academically honest you know Jesus is
described in the Bible as having breast
feed you know so he was most likely
equal to what he was see of Palestinian
be looking like today or Jordanian or
someone from that area you know you're
someone red and bronze he was brown you
know kind of like and he had woolly hair
so you you know you is not he was he
wasn't a white boy you know let's just
split it like that and that's just the
way it is no it was not a white boy so
you hear brass brass colored feet that's
brown in yeah and brown yeah more likely
he looked like an Arab like Semitic
right he was Semitic so exact Wow
many people are just really amazed to
hear this right now yeah I'm sure but
that goes against say that you know I
mean sadly people are trying to prove
something that agenda if you look at the
history of colonialism and so on this
has been used a lot to show superiority
of Caucasians over non-caucasians and
taking over justifying and take
inordinate goddess is why tonight and
that's why in the movie Malcolm X from
the acid priests like what what colors
you know listen if the priests turns to
the statuses this is obvious you know
like and that's this is not correct
right
and if any of anyone's honest enough to
look into the history of colonization
and so on and don't find some very scary
stories and scary things as well people
justify you know taking over other
people and how they consider them less
human than them if not even nonhumans
all right do you see it ironic when many
people fall into doubts they'll get into
matters that are more scholarly that
need more contextualization and when you
dig a little deeper you see that the
basic fundamental theology of Islam a
lot of time is overlooked because you
don't see people arguing about the tokey
the pure monotheism and many people they
jump over learning the basics of this
and they get into these other areas and
then they get into a land of confusion
when they skip first grade they jump
into college right away that doesn't
make sense do you see this happening
yeah that's probably the default right
and again I think it's a somatic right
you you get people to focus on all the
details and you miss the main point
you've definitely not going to study
calculus without knowing basic
arithmetic no hold on but it's know
people are trying to do you know second
and third degree equations without
knowing how to do fractions and that's a
big mistake you know I mean it's not
logic it's not rational so that's why
usually people need to understand and
keep asking about the job and there
isn't that if you don't know who is the
one who legislated this and you know it
doesn't make sense you need to go to
where number one who is God doesn't even
believe in God first of all and who is
God and what is his message what is it
who is prophets prophets and then it
goes set myself you do that anyway with
everything in life and when you move
away from the system be it in your job
in your education and your life you'll
find that you fail at it but somehow
when it comes to faith people get shy of
that and it don't follow that procedure
which is a very simple procedure you
know what I'm saying
how far is Pollan from where you're
originally from Romania neighbouring
closeby isn't it yes yeah very close
yeah tell us what was your reaction or
did you hear about when it was reported
that Poland having one of the largest
marches in Warsaw 60,000 people coming
together and at one part of the protest
they were chanting pray for Islamic
Holocaust did you do you remember it was
yeah yeah well I think that's very very
contradictory because not not too long
ago actually in the history of mankind
the pole is themselves found there's all
being under attack okay I'll be it from
the east or from the West and you know
they're they're being killed and they're
being exterminated left and right in the
world war and here's the arch think this
you know I think it's very very sad to
hear that that people are so ignorant
and they wish for the death of others
here they are hating Islam because of a
certain number of people doing certain
number of attacks and acts which is a
very small number and yet they're
calling for even worse than that so how
are you better than these so-called
people they you hate you know not just
that where's that Christianity that you
so called you know you preached a new
so-called you know you profess of
loving-kindness and that's the thing
when it gets down to the raw deal this
is when the true face of people comes
out with all the respect you know that
if you're gonna gather so many people
marched and call for the you know
Holocaust and so on and using the name
that killed so many you know Semitic or
Jewish people in the world wars I mean
that's very sad that you know you didn't
learn from from what happened in history
so it's just I can just say just sad
Romania what is the status you've
dedicated now your time and efforts into
helping educate the Romanian people in
the Romanian language about the pure
monotheism about the message of Jesus
and
the profit submission to the will of the
creator not the creation Islam how
receptive our people to it how's the
community there fill us in yeah so
Romania has quite a long history with
Islam there's been obviously a lot of
wars between the Ottoman Empire and
Romania and a lot of times the Ottoman
Empire they take over Romania I mean
that's a different story
so remain is that Muslim Muslims have
been Romanian for about 700 years over
generations we have about a hundred
messages
some of them dating back to the Year
1500 so five six hundred years old
message it's very beautiful and most of
the people there who are Muslims are
ethnically turk tatar or gypsy right and
they're good people they're hard-working
a lot of them are farmers and part of
the Romanian society for four centuries
their status there there they're quite
ignorant because after the communist
regime a lot of them just couldn't
practice Islam couldn't learn stuff and
they don't know how to pray properly
they just can't follow the man sometimes
Imams themselves are not very
knowledgeable
there's definitely social issues
depression alcohol abuse abuse other
things poverty the messengers are not
usually opened they only open on Friday
if they open the attendance at the
Friday prayer is very very low and again
the knowledge of the people is very very
low Romania had a big been almost the
population before but again a lot of
them just migrated when the communism
came in they went to Turkey and so on
and establish themselves there so I've
been working with the romaine community
endowment general for about 15 years
since I became Muslim to be honest but
with romaine committed for about five or
six years now is more and it was a bit
difficult at the beginning because yes I
do speak the language but I've studied
Islam in either English or Arabic so the
oils they're difficult to to learn the
terminology and so on but some did not
with time i picked it up
and the Romanians are a bit stubborn
I'll say but they're good people so when
it comes to face their cell because
they're like ethnically Christians you
know and they they take it very
seriously in terms of like okay that's
our identity and we're never gonna you
know become Muslim but the matter of
fact that a lot of them are entering
Islam because once they do hear certain
convincing arguments and information
being presented then of course a person
was who's honest enough and academically
honest and willing to read a bit and
listen but it will definitely definitely
accept the Sun so through the internet
through translating books translating
different pamphlets talking to people
with different projects going on the
ground
visiting Romania and talking to people
so hamdullah we have on steady you know
monthly about five to ten people
embracing Islam so we're trying to
educate them we're trying to help them
to learn how to pray but more more than
just that to learn teach them there
Athena who is God to love God to love
themselves to work together you know to
be part of the business
the community the south part is that the
rest of the world kind of forgot about
Romania or maybe didn't know that
there's Muslims in Romania so there's
really no support and no help from the
outside world I'm not gonna take away
from the brothers have been there for a
long time and did you know do a lot of
good work some of the herbs that came
and studied in Romania medicine and they
married there and their Imams in the
message it or their you know people who
are working the messages but a matter of
fact I mean we have to be honest this is
dour this is not some kind of you know I
just you know we're not just saying
things we need to reach out to to those
19 to 20 million people who are
literally you know they wanted you know
there there's this dissatisfied with
what's wrong with what's going on in the
politics I'm sure a lot of people have
seen the news all the protests it's all
about corruption there's corruption in
the country a lot of the clergy is
involved in politics so you know the the
attendance of the churches are very low
people are educators so they're leaving
the country's remaining is the second
country of people leaving it after Syria
and see here's you know obviously we
know there is
tarnished by war but Romania is not and
people are leaving it you know by the
seconds
but what happens is that when they leave
the country just like it happened to me
they do open up their mind they interact
they see they meet Muslims in the UK and
France and all over the Europe where
they work and they realize that sadly
what would be taught at school and in
our literature sometimes it wasn't true
I'm not saying I'm not taking away that
they might have been some messed up
things that you know some people in the
Ottoman Empire have done no doubt about
it I'm not making excuses for that but
what I'm saying is that you can judge
that you know bigger Islam based what
some people have done that's just messed
up people but look at Islam is worse and
also if you look at the Ottomans if you
do an academic study they've brought so
much goodness to the world so many
systems and they've set up the
foundation so for so many you know
future generations and and so many
societies later on with their systems
you know physical system and banking
systems and railroads and all kinds of
things so you know a person has to be
honest when they talk you can't allow
emotion to just stay over if you want to
be just a sweet talker then okay you are
allowing more to take over if you want
to be an academic and you really want to
understand study and have a intellectual
discussion that you do need to read and
you do need to be as fair as you can
when you make these you know these
statements so that's pretty much the the
the condition of the remains there's
about I would say four hundred thousand
Muslims in Romania right now even though
this statistics year but the latest this
is one 2011 and it was about sixty four
thousand people but that's not correct I
think there's about three to four
hundred thousand Muslims in Romania this
lot of students in remain right now it's
real
you opened and Romania is part of the
European Union so you'll see the
messages you'll see some in the southern
part of Romania you go to some villages
and they're full of Muslims you know I
mean it's a majority has 90% 100%
Musa but again these are remote villages
there's no access sometimes medical care
there's no access to clean water the
massage guitar falling apart because
again they're like five six hundred
years old and they're like that you know
their monuments really their ancient
monuments and we have to try to rebuild
this or we you know to to take care of
them some of the communities do need
help in building some messages
schools teach in students teaching kids
how to read the Quran almost no one
knows how to read the Quran except for
the Imam and even that at some time span
Allah it's not that good you know so
definitely the education is key social
support is key and reclaiming the
identity you know Romania is a perfect
example of different cultures and
different religions living together in
one land you know and apologize itself
that southern part of Romania is the
witness for hundreds of years so people
need to start looking usually when we
look at Dawa we're very very enchanted
and impressed with doing down to the
West you know so is America Canada the
UK South Africa Australia but we need to
look at Eastern Europe as well there's a
lot of countries that have a lot of
beautiful rich heritage Islamic heritage
and the woman cannot forget about those
people need us those people need our
support
and you know I would say it's it's it's
a win-win situation for those who want
to help to get involved because they can
actually in almost parallel you know
open up it's down to this to this it is
beautiful car sharing educating how can
they contact you and get involved now so
come dinner I've been quite active on
the social media so my fest Facebook
page for /al Romani so facebook.com for
/al are all and double-a and I as
Romania the Romanian
okay al are all and double-a and I
that's my main page
hundred I post a lot of the videos there
my trips Romania information about how
they can help they can contact me you
know we haven't read yet organization
has been set up in Canada and we're
working with Romania people want to come
visit Romania is a very cheap cause it's
a very beautiful country is very nice
people they're open to joining us on
some of the trips and then getting
involved there's beautiful people I mean
the Muslims I was very very impressed
because when I went there to the South
you know the Gypsy population and a lot
of people don't know about the Gypsy
populations
other than maybe send Europeans lumps
Bosnians and so on would know about them
but there's different religions within
themselves right so usually gypsies are
known sadly you know for like theft and
crime and so on which is again it's a
misconception you know that's not how
all of them are I grew up with a lot of
very very kind and righteous and loving
gypsies and they're very beautiful
people but you will find some of them of
course banging and song
Carla when I went to the South I mean it
was just amazing to see the respect that
they had you know on seeing a foreigner
or you know someone come on son I'm
remaining but you know I mean it was
just so much respect none of them asked
me for anything it was just beautiful
they brought the little babies out you
know wearing little heat jobs and you
know it's just it was just so beautiful
you'll never hear they call you like oh
joy you know I'm sure maybe this is the
same thing in Eastern Europe so it was
very very nice to see you know the
communities yeah they're poor yeah they
don't have all the Mercedes and the big
pillars that some people have in other
parts of the world or in other parts of
the country but they respect people and
they respect themselves so you know
there are brothers and sisters in the
end you know Starla so any wants to get
in touch with me unless but maybe you'll
post the video she'll like and put my
Facebook page as well and we can give
all the informations on all the plans
right now we're basically a focus on
social work on the ground helping people
education as well as restoring some of
the older and sad [ __ ]
a lot of senators well they need to be
cleaned up
as long as the bushes that really not
again this block senators because
there's a lot of presidents in Romanian
before the Communists so that those need
to be clean up so again message it's
Social Work 732 be clean up education
and of course down to the nonsense the
non-muslims are are willing to listen
they need it's done they're looking for
you know salvation they're looking for a
system other than what they know so far
and we're not a forced sound and we just
haven't tell them what it is educate
them and the worst thing that can come
out of that people are not be so
ignorant and the Olson bridges you know
I mean so there's this there's a lot of
work to be done thank you very much and
when you say sharing Islam is this the
same message that every prophet that was
sent by the Creator came with that
message in Arabic la ilaha illa allah
muhammad rasul allah that there's
nothing worthy of worship this message
that when people hear it there's really
not much you don't hear people debating
this it just connects with the human
nature and can you say it also in the
Romanian language so for any Romanian
listening can identify with it I said in
Arabic I'll translate in English that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the Creator who created you and Muhammad
just like Jesus Moses Abraham he was the
final messenger they was messages that
preceded him and they came with that
same message worship the One God don't
worship the creation there's nothing
worthy of worship except him and
Muhammad is the final message how would
you translate that in Romanian there was
always that constant Loyola and the
variable was always the prophet so used
to be like allah rasool allah used to be
lion allah moosa so much with Delilah
Ibrahim used to be like a la essence
Allah and then his eye so no doubt the
but the concept was always lies Allah
and the last prophet came and messengers
from Muhammad peace upon and in Romanian
you basically famous to recess and exist
and it wasn't even started in a fast
Allah Channel
you must resist fulfill to Muhammad yes
mrs. Jarrow professed to ruin this is
this how you will translate in Romanian
that is powerful that resonates with the
heart and soul and with that masha'Allah
thank you very much brother for being
with us and shallow faculty can get
involved and if they want to visit
contribute they can hook up with you